من عمان ينضم الى اللواء فايز دكتور فايز
الدوريه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك يا دكتور لان رئيس هيئه اركان
الامريكيه مارك ميلي كما ذكرنا في الخبر
يكشف عن بدا تدريب قتال ممثل القوات
الاوكرانيه في المانيا في الوقت الذي تجري
فيه روسيا ايضا تدريبات مشتركه
كيف يمكن ان نقرا هذا في السياق الحرب
الدائره في اوكرانيا
هي تاتي ضمن اطار او مخرجات زياره الرئيس
بوتن عندما اصتحب وزير الخارجيه ووزير
الدفاع وتم التاكيد على مجموعه من النقاط
في التعاون
الاقتصادي السياسي العسكري والعسكري يشمل
البعدين التقليدي والنووي وحتى تقنيات
الفضاء في الجانب الاخر الجانب همم
الامريكي الحديث عن همم انا اترجم ذلك
واوضح ذلك بما يسمى التدريب على تحسين
اداء مهاره المعركه للقاضي الصغار لانه
يصعب ان ناخذ همم تدريب الافراد كافراد او
برتبه جندي هذا ينفذ تعليمات وصعب كذلك
تدريب قضيب المستويات العليا هذا الوضع
مختلف اذا هي عمليه تاهيل القاضي الصغار
على عمليات الهجوم والدفاع وهذا ياتي في
ضمن مستوى قاده السرايا فما دون لانهم هم
عصب المعركه ووقودها وبالتالي المهاره
الميدانيه بحاجه الى صقل همم حسب المعطيات
والاستاندرد الامريكي مما يمكن هذه هذه
القاده سواء قادت فصائل او قاده جماعات او
قاده سرايا على استخدام امثل لقدرات
جنودهم لتنفيذها هجمات او الاحتواء جماعه
مقابله الدكتور طيب الان الخبر العاجل
يقول بانه وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه
همم استقالتها من منصبها توقيت هذه
الاستقاله مع الحديث عن تدريب قتال ممثل
القوات الاوكرانيه في المانيا
سيدي يعني دعني افصل بين الامرين التدريب
العسكري في المانيا السؤال هل سيتم ضمن
القواعد الامريكيه الموجوده في المانيا
انا زرت بعض القواعد العسكريه في في
المانيا وفي غير المانيا في كوريا في
اليابان القواعد الامريكيه في هذه الدول
كانها ارض امريكيه
بكل ما في الكلمه من معنى ما يجري عليها
يجري ضمن الاداره الامريكيه ولا يوجد اي
تاثير للدول المستضيفه حتى لا يستطيع رئيس
الدوله في اي دوله ان يدخل قاعد امريكيه
دون موافقه اذا دعني افصل ما بين التدريب
وما بين الاستقاله الاستقاله ارى وقد تتضح
الامور انها تمثل خلافات بينه داخل
المانيا حاول تزويد الجيش الاوكراني
باسلحه هناك الحديث عن همم الدبا اليوبارد
الحديث عن مدافع الحديث عن احتياجات كبيره
مخزونات قليله هناك يبدو اختلاف في وجهات
النظر داخل وزاره الدفاع والمستشاره
المستشاري الالمانيه حول اليه وكميه
ونوعيه وتوقيت التزويد يعني عن استقاله في
جانب او الاستقاله في جانب
اخر لكن ماذا عن بدء او الاعلان عن بدء
نقل صواريخ باتريات من المانيا الى بولندا
في هذا التوقيت
يعني الان هذا يعني تحصين الجبهه الشرقيه
للنيتو قبل ثلاثه ايام كان هناك ارسال
طائرات سواء طائرات مسيره تطير لساعات من
اجل الاستطلاع ارسال طائرات الاكس من اجل
تقديم المعلومات الانوا هناك تسعيد وهناك
اجراءات احترازيه فبالتالي يعني على همم
في التقرير تم الرابط مع سقوط صاروخ اس
300 سقط بالخطا في في الاراضي البولنديه
انا اقول هو تحصين تحصين للوجود لحلف
الناتو على حدود روسيا الان هناك قد
اربطها مع المناورات الروسيه
البيلاروسيه التي تجري لان العذر
البيلروسي ان هناك خطر على الحدود البلار
روسيه الغربي مع بولندا اذا داعيني اقول
هو زياده لتواجد وقدرات دفاع حلف ان ياته
على حدود سواء لبيليا روسيا من جانب او
لفي في رومانيا من جانب الارض
فايزه دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك